nous roulons sur l'autoroute du pétrole
au coeur du texas 50 milliards de baril
d'or noir serait enfuie dans ces plaines
désertiques medellin la capitale du
pétrole aux états unis vit un boom
inattendu
on savait que le texas et est assise sur
d'immenses réserves dit l'ex maire de la
ville
mais personne ne savait affirme us péri
comment extraire ce nouveau pétrole de
schiste grâce aux nouvelles technologies
le texas a triplé sa production en cinq
ans vit ce clown c'est le rêve américain
gonflés aux stéroïdes ici tout le monde
en profite gareth price travail dans le
pétrole depuis l'âge de 22 ans
en quatre ans il s'est payé une corvette
comptant un camion et une maison neuve
henrik b je gagne dit-il environ 160
mille dollars par année
c'est ici que l'on creuse jusqu'à trois
kilomètres dans le sol pour faire
jaillir le pétrole
trendy et réduire touche plus de 90
mille dollars par année
j'aime ça dit il
c'est ici que je peux faire de l'argent
c'est mieux d'y edwin que de travailler
dans un bureau ou encore dans un fast
food
des pompes il y en a partout sur le bord
des routes près des commerces et même
derrière les résidences you back
l'ex maire de medellin on a deux à
seulement 300 mètres de sa maison
il y a quatre ans un producteur décide
de creuser en toute légalité sur son
père chaque mois
j'étais sous le choc mais on s'habitue
il trouve moins drôle cependant de ne
toucher à aucun des millions de dollars
en redevances au texas c'est premier
arrivé premier servi
outre stevens est propriétaire des puits
dans la cour de l'ancien maire son
entreprise en possède cinq mille aux
états unis monsieur stevens et
milliardaire dans le ring eh oui et non
nous ferons maintenant à l'horizontale
dès par fractionnement hydraulique
cette nouvelle technique dit il permet à
un seul puits de produire jusqu'à 1000
baril par jour dix fois plus qu'un puits
conventionnels mais le vent tour les
nouvelles technologies d'extraction
controversé coûte plus cher la
dégringolade du prix du baril de pétrole
fait mal de garrett est maintenant sans
emploi
tout le monde retient son souffle à
medellin même les plus riches
j'y pense deux fois affirme autrui
stevens avant d'embaucher de nouveaux
travailleurs
ce qui compte pour moi c'est que les
etats unis soient indépendants ils sont
maintenant le troisième producteur de
pétrole au monde avec le dernier boom
les américains sont plus prêts que
jamais du rêve de l'autosuffisance ici
christian latreille radio-canada à
midland au texas